well i enjoyed watching the two episodes
that i got to see of the show i think
that um
it's a really fun sweet show and
for you i mean you've played good guys
heroes bad guys villains all of that and
you've done both exceptionally well
but on this show you get to play the
everyday guy who's a dad who loves his
wife and his family
what was appealing about that for you
what made that something you wanted to
do
i think
it's a nice departure from um
some of the more action-y things i've
done and
also the more and more serious dramatic
things and of course you know during
this time in pandemic and because i'm a
hawaii resident
it was very appealing that they were
going to shoot in my backyard
and um and i think that the people
behind it the producers and the creators
i really enjoyed a lot of their work
that they had put together and
and the combination of all those things
and working in hawaii and being able to
play a local guy i thought i could add a
lot to it because i was raised in the
islands so you know those there was a
lot of pluses
you know to keep me on the board
had you been familiar with doogie howser
did you know
what that was
um i i was
yes i mean i've seen the show you know i
used to watch it when i was younger and
then um
um i thought it was very appealing and
you know when they thought when i
thought about a reboot and then i
thought about the reimagining of of you
know a young girl and then
um sort of the mother being more of the
uh
comrade in in arms with her and the
father being kind of like
this
bit of a you know different kind of
character more laid-back more like local
island style kind of
uh surfer guy i thought ah this could be
really interesting so
i think
it helped i think having a platform or
having the foundation of the dookie
hauser show um really to to
as a jumping point for this
i think it really helps too that it said
really early on that it's like it was a
tv show in this world and
the connection is because you know it's
used as a nickname
for his daughter but it's not something
that you have to feel beholden to that
you also get a sense of freedom with it
that you don't have to
you know stick to a certain expectation
yeah um yeah and that that kind of
opened it wide open because especially
with the kind of things we did in the
new episodes
with uh kami aloha i mean we we
a lot of it is a big adventure too you
know there's a lot of outdoor stuff
there's a lot of you know in the ocean
things and um i think it really kind of
broadened it instead of just you know
keeping it indoors or or
um
you know in in a house or in a hospital
or
it's just kind of like widen the the
dimensions of it
when you have such a beautiful backdrop
to work with is it ever challenging not
to be distracted by where you are and
the sheer beauty of everything while
you're also trying to make a tv show
yeah absolutely i mean you're sitting
there you know it's like beautiful sunny
day you know blue skies white clouds and
light trade winds and you're sitting you
know in on what is what is your home set
um or a rented house on the beach and
you're just going you got to pinch
yourself thinking like
i'm working and uh you know this is like
pandemic time and you're thinking like
you're like this is the best you know
the best
probably it can be you know that and and
i enjoy that the
that the materials light you know the
materials um you know family oriented
um
you know all those all those that things
that come into play that knowing that
you're you know creating a show for
for that demographic the family watching
it together i mean it's very comforting
i mean it's a nice
it's a nice appeal
your character is also very drawn to the
ocean it seems to be the thing that
really centers him
why is that something so important to
him is that really
you know what kind of what keeps his
focus in his life
yeah i think um
you know
in creating
in creating the character with courtney
kang and
and discussing it with jake kazdin and
and and all that we we kind of came to
that point that
um benny kameloha
you know that's his kind of like zen
that that's where he finds his piece and
that's where he centers himself
so whenever troubles arise or he he
realizes someone else is in in a crisis
he always says oh go into the ocean and
it's a very hawaiian thing um you know
there's been a lot of stories within the
hawaiian culture about people who have
had injuries uh broken necks and things
like that and and you know the old old
people say go down the ocean you know
say this say this you know little prayer
and throw water on your neck three times
and just go sit in the ocean and he's
you know a lot of people swear by like
not having to go through the surgery or
for an injury and they've been you know
healed and don't have any more pain
um so there's a lot of you know
believability and i think in in in some
of the stories that we create around
benny going back to the ocean
um there's a lot of foundation to it
culturally and um i think it you know
creates a very authentic authentic
hawaiian authentic hawaii kind of like
uh cultural thing that we infuse into
the show
also um you know i think with benny it's
um
a lot of it is the ohana is his thing
the family unit is is
is his value um and so the priority is
that he supports
uh clara and um um peyton um dougie
lahella um in their you know
medical
medical quests
i love the opening of the show and our
introduction to these characters going
from you know this father and daughter
surfing to
then a driving test to her then saving
someone's life because it seems like in
the first five minutes we learned so
much about
the importance of family and then we see
how she's you know this teenager who
doesn't have her license yet and then
she's a doctor saving someone's life
so do you feel like that is really that
first five minutes is a good
representation of what people can expect
from this season of the show
absolutely i think it's so smart to just
get right into it you know really you
know focus on this central character and
her her wits her her
talents and um also her youth and
i think that that stacks it up just
perfectly for you know what the rest of
the show is and all the episodes
was that always the opening from the
first time you had read the script or
did they develop that more was that
something that was always on the page
from day one
from what i read yeah from when i from
what was brought to me for the pilot
that was definitely um
sort of the standard i mean that was
laid out pretty clear
i think it says a lot that this guy used
to work in finance and he gave that up
and now he's running this
shave ice flower truck
and spending time with his family
what who who was he before
when he was working in finance how
different was he and and what was his
life like before all of this
i i think you know building the
backstory for benny was that there was a
lot of stress there was a lot of um
grouchiness i think the a little more
intense kind of guy kind of character
and and i believe he is falling into the
rabbit hole a bit with that and i think
there was at a point there was an
epiphany that that came around like hey
you know it's like wait a minute my
happiest times was when i was growing up
in in the islands and and so i think
when he and clara decided to have a
family
that was probably one of the uh key
factors and moving back was you know he
wanted to raise his kids in that
environment that atmosphere and i think
you know he also wanted to spend more
time with with them and be more more
there for them and i think you know like
he's i think one of the lines i have in
is like my two favorite things
shave ice and flowers
and um you know flowers make everyone
happy you know and and shave ice is kind
of an island tree
so a little bit of sugar a little bit of
uh floral scent and um
and i think in that way
you know he really embodies that that
sense like
you know he's probably not gonna make a
whole lot of money but he will make
people happy and and he'll see smiles on
their faces and it really conveys that
sense of the aloha spirit that that
carrying that that giving spirit so
i think it is so symbolic of of
creating a character like that
especially being the father of the
family
so often we see families on tv that are
dysfunctional or that have a lot of
tension between them and i love how the
parents on this show are the hot parents
who love each other and they have a
great relationship
what do you most enjoy about the
relationship between these two and what
do you think it was that originally
brought them together
um i think the differences i think you
know the the
the odds that um
um
she's you know she's from the mainland
and caucasian and he's from the islands
and sort of ethnic and
and i think you know that there's
certain mysteries that you look into
another person and and you find that are
like wow it's like that's interesting i
never knew that or
and you're intrigued by it and i think
clara in her own world was intrigued by
benny's you know background and
and um
and his upbringing and
and being of another culture and i think
that that was part of it and and
probably that that he was she probably
recognizes that he was pretty flexible
he was pretty adaptable um being able to
jump from
an extreme world like finance um into a
sort of independent uh
uh
businessman like a shave ice guy
there's something so fun and playful
about the dynamic too what what if you
enjoyed working about working with
kathleen rose perkins and
i mean does she bring a lot of fun to
the scenes that you guys do together
absolutely i mean
kathleen is just nice she's she's she's
kind of your auntie actress because she
doesn't act like an actress she she's
just kind of like
no errors about her and just easy going
and quirky and
funny and willing to like you know
go the goofy route you know at the drop
of a hat and and just has just has this
kind of like ease about her going
through it and and also kind of combined
with
sort of a franticness which which works
so well you know for
for the character
and i think you know we play well off
each other i'm kind of a more centered
more calm more
you know more like a benny and then
she's maybe that's why we're cast as
such
did you guys have a moment when this
whole family really felt like it clicked
and the chemistry and the dynamic was
really present or has it been more of a
gradual thing than that
i think you know everybody had uh
everybody was kind of grateful for being
able to you know be on a set
um when we first started filming and i
think you know the gratitude showed that
all of us came in with kind of a
humility because you know everything was
going on around us and we all kind of
felt like we were in the same boat
together
and we were sitting in this what they
called a green room which is a second
story of of the of the house where we
were filming at right on waimanalo beach
and we all kind of looked out and we all
sat around and
and we were all you know getting tested
and then and all that thing so we felt
kind of like you know a safe zone and we
just started talking it was a very
relaxed atmosphere and i think that
really helped kind of just engage and
get to know who each other you know was
and
and each other's hobbies and likes and
dislikes and
who was on the phone the most time
you know all these all these factors
but
i think that really kind of
cemented it because there was a lot of
familiarity but then yet there was this
newness that um
you know even with the kids it's like
fantastic to to learn you know where
they're from what they've done you know
what their aspirations are
and i think that really helps you know
create that bond
yeah i love that these are three very
different children that this couple has
but they still
seem to really try to relate to all of
them and to
embrace how different all three of them
are
yeah and then that's the thing you know
we have the genius kid and then you have
the the what we call in the islands
colloid we have the colloid the
mischievous one you know kind of um
in kai and then you have this uh quirky
uh young one which you know kind of has
these fantasy
things and and it
and that that that's interesting i mean
just having to deal with them at the
different ages as well as their
different personalities i think you you
really gotta spend time with each with
each child i think that's probably why
they didn't add five kids to the to the
mix
i also love that he can be the sweetest
dad but then he can also threaten his
daughter's date with bodily harm
is it fun to get to have those moments
too and get to show that he he can be a
little more threatening when he needs to
be
yeah and i think the threat is kind of
in play and ingest but it's also there's
something you know there's a little
underlying like you know uh
concern
and and i think that's a fun thing
because yeah also like in hawaii it's a
very hawaii thing you know it's like
everything's very kind of like
heavy-handed in a way i mean the times i
was raised maybe not now but
um you know it kind of comes from that
heavy-handedness and a little bit of um
you know
machoism a little bit of threat there
and but then there's a there's a
kind of
throw it out the window kind of thing
too you know just kind of like ah just
you know
it's all right it's all right that kind
of thing you know but
you know it's fun it's fun to play it
when you're someone who's working on a
show like this where you don't
know everything ahead of time you don't
know where everything is going or what's
going to happen for all these characters
do you like to have answers do you ask a
lot of questions of your show runner do
you know what benny could be up to in
season two
how do you approach that aspect of it
i think i think what we've
gained to try and establish
in building benny in the first season
um
i kind of you know and the writers kind
of give you a heads up like what they
want um
and where they felt benny might go and
because i think we established so much
diversity within his character there's
like so many places you can go with it
um so i'm i'm wide open you know
to all those changes and and new
horizons and um you know i think it's
going to be fun to see even more you
know
the development of it
you've had quite the history with disney
from mulan to jungle book to lilo and
stitch and now you're doing
this series
what does it mean to you to be a part of
the disney family and to keep working
with them at different points in your
career
well i think you never set out to work
with one studio it just it just kind of
fell into place it's like you know back
when um jungle book came up i think i
thought wow you know regular keep right
there keeping some um jungle book i i've
always had uh
a childhood kind of like fascination
with that character
so i think when stephen summers
was putting it together i was like yeah
i want to be a part of it i don't be a
part of it i wasn't you know thinking
like oh i want to work for disney it was
more it was more of the the
you know that they had the the license
to it um
and then lilo and stitch was another you
know fascinating
foray into into working with them
because you know that was a hawaii theme
thing and probably that was the only
other
local boy hawaii local boy thing that
i've done you know in my career
um
uh contemporary and
that that was you know another kind of
island that was so long ago
it seems like and then you know
now you know i've been a part of mulan
and things it's
interesting you know if i can keep it
going with with these type of projects
and and because mulatto was very
challenging for me it's very you know
it was really tapped into my chinese
ancestry um so all of these things kind
of like have bearing in in i think who i
am and and my cultural background and
and everything
all those things are so significant
i look to that they
have seen you as the hero and the
villain because you were pretty
terrifying in milan
oh good you know i think the director of
that nikki carroll she really you know
pushed me to
go deep with with that character what
and her her perception of what that
character wanted what she wanted that
character to be
so that you know working with someone of
that you know caliber
in nikki she's um you know
she's awesome i mean she just really
pushes her actors to where you know she
envisions the the character in the film
are you someone who also has
frequented the disney theme parks were
you
you know a theme park person too or was
that not something that was
ever a part of your life
well i think you know
disney just in you know filtrates to
everything when we are a child
um and then you know i i had an
opportunity after um jungle book they
they allowed me to take my family and my
um
siblings and everyone to to
anaheim the park and um just run run
wild and and you know get to the front
of all the lines
and that was a real treat you know it
was like a once-in-a-lifetime treat for
us
um you're not don't have to wait around
and being escorted through it and and
you know recently having it you know
free-handed everything um so i think
those are the perks um working for the
mouse and uh
um and you know so many other things i
mean they've expanded so much since
jungle book times you know and and it's
interesting to see
you know uh how massive they have become
at this point in your life
what do you look for
in a project and a role is there
are there things that you know you
definitely aren't interested in doing or
is it just more about
how you feel when you read something
um
sometimes it's just an opportunity that
that you know comes upon and it's like
wow you know you know i get to work here
i get to work with so and so
um i'd like to do it and sometimes it's
it's more inspired by the story
um by the
by the script
um and then
oftentimes it's
you know
i like to be
i'm kind of at that point where i really
want to
i want to push
so i'm looking for something you know
i'm looking at things that are going to
like
give me that challenge
because you know
you know after so many years of doing it
you you know you can jump on a show and
just kind of like
you know pedal the bike and then you
know how to ride a bike
but there's often times when you know
like now where i think oh it'd be cool
you know i just started learning
something on a whole another level
um that'll
help me
develop even more sort of your you know
self-development kind of thing
um so i'm always looking for projects
that that do develop my character my
interests um
that will challenge me and and and
you know make it
make it worth the effort like you feel
like you worked
what was the earliest experience you've
had on a set that was a really positive
really memorable experience for you that
you feel like you really learned from
and
and that really
you know was a turning point for you in
your career
oh it was early on um it was early on i
was i was 24 or 25.
um i work with this director named
vincent ward from new zealand and we did
this film called map of the human heart
and um you know it was with a stellar
cast um
and he was traveling to these very
remote
exotic places up in the canadian arctic
and um that kind of was the projection
for me back then was like
you know if if i had the opportunity to
work and continue to work in this
business
um that was my projection i wanted to go
you know to these faraway places places
where you wouldn't necessarily go as a
tourist
um
or visit and um and i love the great
outdoors i love being you know on
adventures and and it it it's it checked
all those boxes
i worked with the international cast
and um
and that was that was the the one that
kind of made the big shift for me um
and that was uh you know my first um
lead first title lead in a you know in a
picture and a feature and it was you
know
working kind of in a big budget our art
house as we called it back then art
house films now they call them
independent films
[Laughter]
but um yeah that was that was a fabulous
experience i took away so much from it
and um those are some also some gnarly
challenges you know i think at that
young age and so you know when i hearken
back to
you know episodes in my career where i
felt really stellar and i you know that
i you know that's the kind of
experiences i wanted i think it remains
true
i appreciate you talking to me about the
show and about everything i i'm having
so much fun with the show i watched
doogie howser when i was a kid so it's
it's been really fun to watch this take
on
everything
[Laughter]
yeah i think it's bright it's colorful
you know there's so much hawaii stuff in
it and i think it's just gonna add so
much uh layers to to the doogie reboot